from now
we're live now thank you
do you want to do a roll call please
anne
yes leader we'll start with you if you
can just confirm you can see in here
yes i can see and hear the proceedings
thank you
and i understand council pemberton will
be joining us a little later today
so we move to councillor barca
hello i'm here
councillor barker here sorry thank you
um councillor cargill have you joined us
yet i believe you were in another
meeting
yes cargill is saying hold on on
whatsapp
so he's going to be here momentarily
okay thank you
councillor harvey trevor harvey yes
could hear and see thank you very much
thank you councillor jennings councillor
jennings here i can hear and see your
proceedings
thank you counselor kettle is hopefully
joining us are you here yet
no he had another meeting which he was
hoping was finished by 12th but again
hopefully
momentarily he will join door councillor
parry
councillor parry here i can see and hear
all proceedings thank you
thank you councillor shenson hi good
afternoon i can hear
and see all proceedings thank you very
much thank you and we have with us
councillors junaid dixon
and o'donnell thank you thank you um
uh do we have any apologies for absence
no apologies just um a couple of the
councillors who will be a little late
i believe we've been joined by
councillor cargill
and councillor kettle
councillors cargill and kettle can you
just confirm
you're in the meeting uh councillor
kettle confirmed i can
buy that in the last two two seconds i
can hear and see
what's going on yes likewise i i
apologize for that care leader
uh thank you councillors katelyn cargill
uh so disclosures of interest anyone
i'll take that as a no so right
moving on swiftly uh you all had the
paper revenue and capital budget
2021 22 to 25
26. uh what i would say
in introducing this paper is
producing a medium-term financial
strategy
that preserves services in 2122
and meets the minimum reserve criteria
in 2526
has been no mean achievement and i think
our
thanks go out to the offices for all the
background work that they've done on
this
uh just to pick up some of the key
points because i think it is important
that we all understand
fully the background to the creation of
this medium-term financial strategy
one of the main influencing factors on
this has been
the impact of kerbic 19 uh that
over the medium-term financial strategy
period
this has cost this council or is
estimated to cost this council
seven and a half million pounds
in the context of the scale of our
operations that is a very
significant sum and
that has made it important that we
identify
savings that will need to be made as i
said
already that we have maintained services
in
2122
also just to be absolutely clear we've
had a one-year spending review
settlement we are awaiting a
much longer term financial settlement
but that is not likely to come
until the end of this year and will
cover the periods
2022 and 23 onwards
so at the moment all we've been able to
do is
estimate uh and make the best
assumptions we can for the years beyond
21.22
the base budget's been prepared on the
basis of an increase of
in council tax for 21.22
of five pounds and beyond that
uh council tax will increase by two
percent
one of the things if you look at
paragraph two six
is the base budget takes account of the
current position in relation to the
level of interest
this is really important because over
the last
week or so the
sentiment may well have changed whereas
uh until then it was expected that
interest rates would stay
very low for a substantial length of
time
as outlined in table two there now
seems to be an emerging view that
interest rates could begin to rise
much sooner than anticipated
that is a huge risk because that will
affect the government's implicit fiscal
strategy
of being able to borrow extremely
cheaply
into the foreseeable future that may not
hold if we look at
uh paragraph two
it demonstrates that we've already taken
action
to reduce costs some tough decisions
have already been taken
and that's outlined in the bullet points
on page 3.
if we move on uh
in paragraph three three
it highlights the fact that uh grants
new homes bonus and retained business
rates
are all subject to change or even
removal
from 20 22 23 onwards
and indeed what you can see in table
four on page five
is the actual impact excuse me second
the impact of the removal of new homes
bonus
this declines from 4.3 million
in 2122 to 0
in 2324
given the scale of our budget that
is a very very significant change
and it explains why there are some tough
decisions
contained in the budget going forwards
uh it should also be very clear and
that's contained in power
4 6 that the local government
provisional
financial settlement assumes that we put
council tax up by five pounds
so that is the assumption the government
works on
the table 4
shows the revenue budget projections
incorporating new cabinet proposals
if we move on to table 5
para 73 on page 8
that demonstrates that the reserves
position
at the 31st of march 2026
is still within the two and a half
million
limits we have on reserves
however it needs to be pointed out that
even in that year there is still a
deficit
of over a million what this means in
very simple terms
is that even on the assumptions we've
made in this budget
there may well still be some difficult
decisions ahead
because we will still have to find
additional savings of a million
for the years beyond 25 26.
so that in summary
is the key issues within the budget
uh like i say we preserved services in
2122
we have done that by the means of
reallocation of earmarked reserves
which have been substantial and also
increasing revenue
through car park charges and the green
waste charge
so uh i wonder if my
esteemed and valued colleague councillor
harvey
has any comments to make at this point
thank you leader um i
i think you've encapsulated it pretty
well um
the the essence of the problem that we
face
is the pandemic
the changes in the structure of our
finances particularly new homes bonus
and the way and what and the lack of a
spending review
we've had three years where we've had
annual reviews as opposed to the
normal four yearly review the world is
uncertain as you've referred to
the prospect for interest rates views
will vary but
clearly with the government which has
borrowed vast amounts of money
the implications of rises in interest
rates and what that will do when it
trickles down to the implications for
local government finance
that could be significant
from our perspective we have
um in the circumstances uh
i think achieved i wouldn't quite say a
miracle but
certainly we've reflected our values
that in
in the fourth coming year for which this
budget is the prime
focus we will not as far as i'm aware
we will not be cutting any services that
we provide
to residents i think that's quite an
achievement given the financial
pressures
so we are filling the gap until we get
a spending review which enables us to
budget in a realistic way over a
four-year period
so that the figures beyond 2122
that appear in the medium-term financial
strategy
are our best guests uh and and the one
thing we can say about them i suspect is
they won't turn out to be like that
things will change
and hopefully the spending review will
enable us to tackle the subsequent four
years with a lot greater degree of
certainty
than we've been able to tackle the
current year we have
filled the gap so to speak in the
current year's finances
by drawing on three sources one
we have moved around reserves
two we have saved costs
in various innovative and imaginative
ways
and thirdly we are going to increase
revenue
from sources which certainly if if julie
julie lewis's figures on take up on the
greenways bin
so far show that that is a an accepted
and well well provided value for money
solution so those three areas reserves
internal savings and good management and
increased revenue from charges and
council tax
taken together they will enable us to
provide a budget for next year which
shows a small surplus
and we hope the world pans out exactly
as we hope thank you mr chairman
thank you councillor harvey i think uh
summarizing all that i think we've
provided
uh very responsible and very effective
community leadership in producing the
budget that we have
uh councillor junit has a very specific
query on page 29
lost income and i think in all honesty
this is something that
mr hill may be able to respond to
thank you it is it really is saying
uh in this column on lost income that
the uncompensated losses
uh will not be covered by government
even beyond this year
for the next three years so a three
million uh
gap will arise uh because the current
government is not supporting local
councils
adequately um so i do hope that lobbying
is being
made to central government uh to say
look we do need that
long-term uh revenue for councils and
that we cannot
support having uh these uncompensated
losses
to this degree so i do hope you you can
um you can clarify that because that's
three million even beyond
uh this current uh this next year uh so
it you know we're anticipating
uncompensated lossing
losses going on as far as 2024-25
which to my mind seems quite um
unfair that government is not
compensating those losses
thank you councillor junior perhaps i
could initially respond to that
i think we have to remember that kobe 19
has dealt quite a devastating blow to
the economy
gdp for 2020 is estimated to be down
over 11 percent we're now facing another
lockdown
the reality is in the first quarter it
is
likely that the gdp will fall further
the government has borrowed at least 400
billion
to try and plug the whole that's a mere
20 percent of gdp
uh councillor harvey commented earlier
on the impact that any increase in
interest rates would have
there is a very brutal reality it may
well become much harder to borrow
and much harder to cover every
eventuality and i think we have to be
realistic
we have lobbied government we've lobbied
government tremendously
there are frequent meetings of the
district council's network
with ministers present and the comments
always go in about the particular
pressure
on district councils however i think it
is realistic
to budget on the basis of the figures on
page 29. uh i don't know whether you
wish to
add anything uh mr hill
yes thank you uh i only that
um the government has been collecting
data on the impact of covert
1900 councils ever since the the
the first lockdown they they do that
monthly
and we've been providing monthly figures
and
annual figures on each return
they've given us notification that the
next return for the first time
will include uh 2021-22 figures as well
so
it does look as if the government is
turning attention to the future
and looking at what impact it is going
to have on local authorities
not just in the current year but in next
year as well so that may be an
indication that they
are considering how they will deal with
that
in future so it may be better news
perhaps
i would just uh actually also add in
their
counselor junior that if more money is
forthcoming
then that means some of the savings we
are projecting for 22
23 and beyond and some of the cuts there
will not need to be made but we cannot
count on that at the moment
so members of cabinet any further
comments from people
councillor parry
thank you leader i just wanted to
express my thanks to george hill and his
team
and also to councillor harvey for the
extensive work
they have clearly had to do under
extreme pressures
and in extremely difficult short
circumstances
um and i would just like that to go on
record on the minutes
that um we we are extremely grateful for
the additional
hard work and diligence and feel we're
very fortunate to have
such professional expertise when both
our senior management and cabinet thank
you leader
i would fully endorse everything you
said counselor parry
and i hope that is fully reflected in
the minutes
counselor juno do you have another
question
yes uh actually two questions if you
don't don't mind me asking
one is that if there is um improved
um provision by government if the next
year's
settlement improves would you really
look at some of the cuts that have been
made because you said that there were no
cuts to services
actually there are cuts to services
because the parking permit for
um people that are pensioners is a cut
to a service
uh would they would you look we look at
that
as a as a provision um and
also um there is a question there was a
we've asked twice about land charges are
we prepared
for the um revision in stamp duty
um are we prepared as a council for that
there was an article in today's guardian
which is reflecting that this is quite a
story that might
happen so i'd just like to seek
assurance that
land charges within the council uh is
already
able to um to face up to the march
deadline
for the provision of stamp duty um
at the moment uh thank you councillor
junior
i'm not totally convinced what that has
to do with the budget but i'm sure
councillor parry will answer anyway
thank you leader and um i'd just like to
reassure councillor junaid
a number one um the land charges search
times
for full official searches for which we
get a fee
are now down to four to five weeks
um there has been a significant increase
in
personal searches which are being turned
round within two to three weeks
for which we don't get a fee but
obviously a personal search doesn't have
the insurance backed
um guarantees but what i can
say because i also work
um in a part-time capacity and an estate
agent so
i'm fully aware of the situation a our
team
are fully briefed up and raring to go
the biggest delays that are being
experienced
are not through land search land
searches
but actually through surveyors
solicitors trying to ensure that they
can
complete all the contractual work
and also the banks the mortgages so in
fact
as far as sdc is concerned
providing purchasers have
already applied for their searches
for any house transaction that is going
to take place
before the end of march a that should
from our perspective we can service that
and any delays are more likely to arise
through a long chain through solicitors
not being able
to get all the information they are
required
to exchange and then complete
so from our perspective we have as you
know doubled our team
we are down to four to five weeks on
official land searches and that
also includes a non-working period over
christmas and new year
and we are also community communicating
extensively
to the land search agents so they are
fully aware
but unfortunately from time to time it
can be very easy
for other parties perhaps to blame
put the blame at sdc's door because
there were delays
earlier last year but from our
perspective
providing purchasers and solicitors
put their claim in in reasonable time
we will we will supply the searches
julie thank you thank you for that very
sort of response counselor parry
i'm picking up your first uh query
counselor juniored on the uh
parking permits if we get more money for
from government then we will have to
look at all the proposed savings we've
got beyond 22
23 and decide which is the priority to
fund
councillor o'donnell thank you leader um
just a couple of things um i would also
like to echo the thanks that's been
offered to
george and the team of officers
including council harvey for working in
such difficult circumstances
i'm reassured to hear that should we get
a better settlement from government then
all of this will be
um revisited again i'm just going to
pick up on what councillor june had said
because i also as you know have been
banging on really about the fact that
removing
the permit for the over 65s especially
for my rural residents
does seem a little harsh um and that's
what we've also picked up from members
of the osc committee
and i the reason i'm relieved to hear
that you will be revisiting is because
when local businesses are facing the
difficult as they are to be looking at
25
increase in car parking along with
everything else they're trying to
achieve may seem a little harsh for them
but the fact that this is the worst case
scenario
is is reassuring and just to pick up on
what council parry said
i've referred a number of inquiries
about land charges you're quite right
councilor parry
it often isn't down to sdc is people
perhaps
not following the correct route for that
thank you
thank you councillor shenton
thank you chair um in actual fact you
said well
exactly what i was about what i was
going to say about permits in the round
the only other thing i will add um an
answer to
to council o'donnell is that the
increases were
20 were 20 that's the proposed
increase on chart on car park charges
but it's 20 pence it's
it's a 20 sounds a lot on on low fees
it's 20 pence and even bid
themselves and now accepting actually
this is reasonable so it's
not quite as it seems when we just talk
about percentages it seems higher than
the the actual hard cash thank you
councillor shenzhen
councillor barker
sorry i mean muted moved um
i i just want to react slightly on land
charges
and give a massive massive vote of
thanks
to councillor parry who
with the team in land charges has made a
phenomenal
difference and to mesa
mason ash as well leaving that and
completely revolutionizing what we do
if if anybody here remembers the states
that our land charges were in
on paper probably not that much more
than 12 months ago
and so a job that did needed doing for
absolutely donkeys years has been done
we've changed the system we're rolling
it out and
i don't think that there is any room
here for
negativity about our land charges we've
made such a fantastic difference and i
just want
that to be on record as well thanks
thank you councillor barker councillor
harvey
um i hesitate to make this point because
it may seem
trivial in a matter of semantics but
i'll make it in any case
i i made the claim that i think as far
as this year is concerned
we haven't cut any service at all
councillor junid
made the point that she thought that the
the withdrawal
proposed withdrawal of the pensioners
permit parking
uh uh
torpedoed that that claim uh
that if i may say so cancer unit is
incorrect
the service we provide is parking
we are providing as much parking next
year as we did
last year the change we're proposing is
a question of the terms upon which we
provide that service
not the service itself trivial a point
may be
but i'd like to be accurate over the
matter thank you
thank you councillor harvey councillor
donald
and councillor pemberton thank you
um leader can i just ask a quick
question obviously we are now all
working remotely
have we made any savings at all with
regards to travel expenses that will be
counted in
i think i'll refer that to mr
council o'donnell i don't have uh
details
of that nature in front of me
mr hill can i read i'm
yes thank you yeah we are making savings
in those areas and they're all included
in the regular monitoring statements
that the cabinet received
and they're not hugely significant
in terms of the budget but they are
there and they are built into that
thank you mr hill councillor pemberton
then councillor cargill
thank you it's an observation uh for
uh both uh councillor o'donnell landfa
councillor junid um car parking across
the district is not
something that is delivered in isolation
by the district
council there is a county council
component uh
particularly within stratford itself
and just to clarify and to confirm that
our officers
continue to engage with
and press the county council to come to
the table
about an integrated approach to parking
in the round
and think and that includes things like
on-street parking
the operation of the park and ride at
bishop um
and ultimately that need that piece of
work needs to come to fruition in order
to
to get to a full picture in the rand and
so
i would just for the avoidance of doubt
uh make it clear that it
is something that we continue to press
you know i am aware that our colleagues
across at the county
have like ourselves had some challenges
around
cove in terms of bandwidth for officers
to look at this but
i know that it is on the deputy chief
executives
uh continuing uh to do
and uh he is pushing that so that we can
actually sort of
get to a point where we we have a full
and rounded strategy that enables people
to
to park that has beneficial impacts for
the for the economy
and minimizes adverse impacts on the
environment
by unnecessary use
of the car so just to really give that
assurance
to to councillor o'donnell and junid
that
we remain on the case about that thank
you
thank you councillor pemberton
councillor cargill
and i think this is probably going to be
the last comment before we move to the
recommendations
excellent i get my last word in there
thank you very much leela
um i was just a little bit concerned
about
about the comments made that oh if we
get an extra bit of funding from
government
we can change some of the savings we
haven't got a clue what's going to
happen in the next few years
we there are unexpected things going to
happen to our
just our local economy let alone the
national one
you've already indicated that in 25 26
we're still looking at a million
pounds loss now unless governments are
extremely generous
we're not going to see that much money
coming coming our way
i would like to think it will we all
have the services and
the parts of services that we would like
to see
retained and remain we can't guarantee
those at this stage you'd be
irresponsible
of us to even think about those at this
stage if in the future if in the round
these these this this funding that we
hope to get from government
does come forward then we can look at
all services but i think we would need
to take a
a deep look at all of the the things we
wish to provide as discretionary
services
in the future thank you leader thank you
councillor cargill i think you are
reinforcing
what i said that the reality is and i
think if we combined
any extra money we get to cover curved
and any financial settlement we will
have to look again at everything
but i generally tend to agree with your
sentiments
that i would not expect a huge amount of
money
to be coming from government i'm afraid
we are probably
in for a fairly difficult time
and i think the budget we have produced
uh
for 2021 22 and the medium-term
financial strategy through to
26 actually reflects that
and with that can i move to the
recommendations on page one
you will see them there uh the
recommendations
are seven in total i'm not going to read
them out because they printed on the
paper
uh but it is recommended that the seven
points be endorsed and recommended for
scrutiny
so with that members of cabinet can i
have your
agreement to those recommendations on
page one
i will take that as unanimous uh
so thank you members of cabinet
and with that uh those recommendations
are approved
thank you leader thank you thank you
thank you